you
you're at Carnegie Mellon University my
lab is really interested in how we can
engineer human tissues both for disease
models the better understand disease
progression outside the body but
ultimately we want to build engineered
tissues that can repair or replace
organs inside the body for different
kinds of therapies well my lab at CMU is
really trying to engineer these human
tissues and I think the most exciting
applications of these are in both drug
development and eventually organ repair
or replacement for drug development
right now it costs billions of dollars
to develop new drugs and that's mostly
because between an animal trial and a
human clinical trial there's really
nothing in between with a 3d engineered
human tissue on the bench top we can
determine if a drug is efficacious for
toxic much sooner at lower cost so that
really increases the quality of the
drugs are developing the longer term
goal and this is more 20 to 30 years out
is creating an engineer tissue that we
can use to repair or eventually replace
an entire organ at sailing and this
could address a wide range of diseases
from heart disease to the lung failure
to kidney dialysis
[Music]